oh hi I'm going to level with you the
only major new video game on retail
shelves this week is super black bass 3d
so let's not talk about it in fact this
week let's just talk about Metroidvania
zeeeee yes now as you might imagine from
the name a Metroidvania is a game that
is sort of like super metroid or
Castlevania Symphony of the Night it's a
2d platformer with a big open world that
you can explore at your leisure finding
new power-ups that allow you to explore
more of the world now the major
downloadable new video game out this
week is inspired by the Metroidvania
style of gaming so let's take a look so
yes the only new game out this week but
you really need to care about is
guacamelee a mexican-themed Metroidvania
for playstation 3 and playstation vita
your luchador character can punch kick
and suplexes enemies into submission but
the games multiple dimension twist means
you've got to be on the same astral
plane as your enemies before you can get
them into a chokehold guacamelee is a
love letter to classic games and you'll
find sly references to them drop
throughout instead of Metroid's chozo
statues guacamelee has chorizo statues
for 15 bucks you get both the ps3 and
the vita version which can share cloud
saves guacamelee is out april nine if
all this makes you feel like you want to
play an actual castlevania you're in
luck available now for the nintendo 3ds
is the original 8-bit entry in the
series now the first castlevania isn't
actually a Metroidvania why because it's
just a straightforward linear platform
game that's broken up into discrete
levels now apart from that this epic
battle between vampire hunter simon
belmont that his nemesis Dracula is one
of the most notoriously difficult games
of the NES era but you're in luck on the
3ds you can save and restore your game
at any point meaning that kill
Dracula might finally be within your
grasp if you cheat your ass off which we
encourage you to do and finally once
you've finished with guacamelee in
Castlevania you might feel a hankering
to go back to the game that started it
all and you'd be in luck on May
fifteenth Nintendo will release super
metroid for the wii u virtual console
this groundbreaking super nintendo game
is considered even today to be one of
the best games ever made and for the
first month that it's available it'll be
just thirty cents thanks to Nintendo's
special promotion now that price will go
up to eight dollars after the first
month but even then it's still a bargain
you can play this version of Super
Metroid all on the Wii U gamepad's
screen so you don't have to take up the
whole TV you don't want to so whether
you want Metroid or Castlevania or a
Metroidvania combination inspired by
both you will have plenty to do in the
next few weeks thanks for joining us and
we'll see you next time on game life